- Il est à peine 6 heures,
le soleil se pointe le bout
du nez, et déjà, certains
n'en peuvent plus d'attendre.
VICKY MEERDING
- On s'est levé à minuit, puis
on est venu ici à deux heures
du matin de Vaudreuil,
pour avoir la chance d'être
vus aujourd'hui.
- En file à deux heures du
matin, Vicky et son conjoint
n'étaient même pas les premiers
arrivés.
CORENTIN LABOURÉ
- Je suis arrivé à muiuit
et demi.
- Installé devant la porte
du bureau de Service Canada,
Corentin a bon espoir de mettre
la main sur son passeport
aujourd'hui.l l part pour
la France demain.
- Ma grand-mère allait pas bien
en début de mois. Puis, ma mère
est partie la rejoindre dès que
ça a commencé àiririrer.
Malheureusement, elle est
décédée entre-temps; ce qui
fait que les funérailles sont
ce week-end et j'aimerais bien
pouvoir y être honnêtement.
- Pour de nombreuses personnes
ici, ce sont plus que
des vacances qui sont en jeu.
Sonia entreprend une cèèère de
camionneuse dans quelques jours.
SONIA DUMONT
- Lundi, je vais commencer à
être sur la route, ça me prend
un passeport parce que je fais
du États-Unis, longue distance.
OPHÉLIE BEAUMIER-PERRAS
- J'essaie d'obtenir
un passeport pour ma petiteSoha,
on veut aller voir la famille
de mon conjoint en France.
- La raison de ce cafouillage,
évoquée par la ministre chargée
de Service Canada, devant le
Comité des ressources humaines
aux Communes, est une explosion
des demandes de renouvellement
de passeports.
KARINA GOULD, ministre Famille,
Enfants et Développement social
- Puisqugegegegens
ne voyageaient pas,
ils ne faisaient pas
de demande de passeport.
- En fait, en 2019, 2,3 millions
de passeports ont été délivrés;
e e e en 2020, première année e
la pandémie, ce nombre a chuté
à 360 000. En 2021, il était
de 1,2 millions, alors que,
cette année, Service Canada
prévoit en émettre
jusqu'à 4,3 millions.
CHANTAL BARBEAU, copropriétaire,
Voyages Malavoy
- On a deux questions qu'on
pose maintenant, avant même
de commencer une vente, c'est :
êtes-vous vaccinés, puis
avez-vous votre passeport?
- Dans cette agence
de voyages, ils sont témoins
de la dududududu tourisme
international.
- Les gens, depuis février,
appelaient, puis on en avait
qui réservaient pour trois
voyages à venir, là.lololololona
Chaire de tourisme Transat,
cet engouement était
somme toute prévisible.
MARC-ANTOINE VACulululululaire
Chaire de tourisme Transat, UQAM
- Il y a trois fois plus
de Québécois qui veulent faire
un voyage hors-Canada que l'an
dernier. Alors, ça explique
pour l l l l l lance dans
les demandes de passeport
et que, là, la demande est
très, très grande.
- Est-ce que j'ai des gens ici
qui voyagent 24-48 heures?
- À l'ouverture des portes
à 8 h 30, ils sont maintenant
près de 250 dans la file
d'attent
BRIGITTE JONCAS
- C'est sûr que ça peut être
plus long, mais de là à être
comme c'est là maintenan
c'est incroyable.
- Service Canada a embauché
600 nouveaux employés et promet
d'en embaucher 600 autres.l l lu
encore allonger les heures
d'ouverture des bureaux
de passeport?
- Il y a personne
qui rentre dans une ligne
qui est pas autorisée.
- Parce qu'obtenir le précieux
documeininininininintenant
relever de l'expoit.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Montréa